HALF-TIME.
18 IN THE SECOND HALF.
A ONE-POINT GAME, UNDER 2 1/2
REMAINING.
CURRY ON THE DRIVE.
THE FLOATER IN THE PAINT, SHORT.
WIGGINS TIPS IT, BUT RIGHT TO
DAVIS.
JAMES RUNNING THE FLOOR.
PASS TO CARUSO, BACK TO JAMES.
AND HE'S FOULED.
DRAYMOND GREEN WOULD NOT LET HIM
GET A LAY-UP.
AND JAMES GOES DOWN, HOLDING HIS
HEAD.
THE OFFICIALS DISCUSSING.
I THINK THEY'RE GOING TO TAKE A
LOOK AT IT AND SEE IF IT'S A
FLAGRANT.
>> Mark: THERE'S CONTACT TO THE
HEAD OF LeBRON JAMES.
IT WILL BE INTERESTING TO SEE
THE CONCLUSION THEY COME UP
WITH.
BUT CLEARLY WITH THE RIGHT HAND
OF DRAYMOND GREEN TO THE HEAD.
>> Mike: THIS IS A HUGE CALL,
BECAUSE IT WILL BE FREE THROWS
AND POSSESSION.
GREEN PICKS UP HIS FOURTH
PERSONAL.
>> Mark: THAT'S GOING TO BE A
FLAGRANT.
>> Jeff: AND IT SHOULDN'T BE.
BUT IT WILL BE.
>> Mike: LET'S BRING IN STEVE
JAVIE.
STEVE?
YOUR THOUGHTS ON DRAYMOND GREEN
AND THAT FOUL?
IS THAT A FLAGRANT?
>> Steve: YOU KNOW WHAT, I'M
WITH JEFF AND I'M WITH MARK THAT
THEY MIGHT CALL IT.
BUT I DON'T THINK IT IS ONE.
HE GOES UP WITH HIS ARMS
STRAIGHT UP IN MY OPINION.
AND LeBRON GOES IN TO HIM.
UNFORTUNATELY, HE LANDS
AWKWARDLY.
FOR THESE REASONS, I DON'T THINK
THERE'S A WINDUP IMPACT,
FOLLOW-THROUGH.
I DON'T THINK THERE'S A SEVERE
CONTACT.
IN MY OPINION, I WOULD SAY IT'S
A HARD FOUL, COMMON FOUL.
>> Mike: ALL RIGHT, STEVE.
THANK YOU.
I'M JUST HEARTENED THAT STEVE
AGREED WITH YOU.
>> Mark: HE DIDN'T AGREE WITH
US.
>> Mike: HE AGREES WITH YOU THAT
YOU WOULD THINK IT SHOULD BE,
BUT IT WILL BE.
>> Mark: CLEARLY, THERE WAS
CONTACT TO THE HEAD.